It's a bird, it's a plane, it's… gone.
Just seven weeks ago, Henry Cavill posted
the news on his Instagram that fans had
been waiting for ever since "Zack Snyder's
Justice League." His long-awaited return as
Superman sent fans into a frenzy as they
looked forward to his continuation of the
character. The celebration was short-lived,
however, with the news breaking on Wednesday
that Henry Cavill was now out as Superman, and
his role in the DC Universe had come to an end.
"You did this."
"I had to."
"You won't let me live."
James Gunn and his co-CEO of DC Studios, Peter
Safran, have spent the last few weeks holed up and
hidden away while they developed what comes next
for DC. And fans have questions regarding who,
if anyone, from the Snyderverse will be making
the jump to the new universe about to take shape.
Given his most recent announcement, you would be
forgiven if you thought Cavill was a lock to stay
in the role. Unfortunately, Gunn and Safran have
different plans, with the director announcing on
Twitter that they're going the younger route
for the Kryptonian, meaning Cavill is out.
The actor also announced his departure from the
role in his own Instagram post, expressing his
sadness but also reminding fans that Superman
still lives. Unsurprisingly, the Internet went
ablaze, with fans expressing their displeasure
with the decision to remove the British actor
when they just got him back. If you're feeling
betrayed, angry, upset, depressed, or simply
dumbfounded, you aren't alone. Social media
has a whole host of people ready to join you.
"Superman is dead. We all wish he wasn't."
The Snyderverse isn't known for
a deep roster of great films,
but there are some bright spots within them, and
Henry Cavill was one of them. Although his darker
portrayal of the character was divisive,
he was largely beloved by the fan base.
His dismissal from Superman brought on many
negative takes, including one poster who wrote:
"I could not be more devastated.
In 1 move you have single-handedly
destroyed every ounce of interest
and enthusiasm I had for DC movies."
Another person agreed with the sentiment, saying,
"This legit makes no sense."
Someone else eloquently let James Gunn know what
it felt like when they read the news, writing,
"Easily the swiftest most precise
kick to the balls I think anyone
has done with all of Superman's
power in all of DC history."
Of course, Twitter isn't the only outlet where
fans reacted to the news — many also took to
Reddit to talk about the revelation that their
favorite Superman actor isn't returning. One
Redditor took a different path and thought
about how Cavill himself must be feeling:
"Wow, that just sucks. I hope he can catch a break
soon. Someone send him some
Warhammer figures to paint."
Finally, there was one user
who wasn't quite as negative,
expressing a little interest in what's next:
"Interested to see where James Gunn
takes the DCU but definitely would
[have] loved to have seen more of Henry as
Superman. Sucks we don't get to see him as
Geralt anymore either. Hopefully he lands
another iconic role in the near future."
This brings up a good point. With all
the news about Gunn's new direction,
there are many, many questions
about where he's headed.
"Consider this mercy."
It shouldn't be surprising that James Gunn and
Peter Safran are cleaning house at DC. While
Disney and Marvel have been doing what Warner
Bros. and DC have been trying to do for a decade,
DC is failing where Marvel is succeeding.
Even without their most well-known characters,
Spider-Man, the X-Men, and the Fantastic Four,
Marvel was able to build a universe that changed
cinema. All the while, DC has taken three of the
most globally well-known characters of all time,
Superman, Batman, and Wonder Woman, and mostly
stumbled in its recent handling of them.
With the announcement that new leadership
is in store for the DC movies, ushering in a
new universe with fresh takes and rebooted
storylines seems to be a solid choice. The
problem is the backlash from a fan base that
wants to see all the aspects they love about
the Snyderverse. Of course, this also raises
more questions about the characters we have
yet to hear about. What will happen with
Jason Momoa after the release of "Aquaman
2"? What about Zachary Levi? Dwayne Johnson?
Is there any point in the Flash movie now?
Some of them expressed their love and support
for Henry Cavill, with Momoa commenting on his
Instagram post,
"love u brother"
along with heart emojis.
Levi commented,
"Hope to catch you in another universe, sir."
There's no question that the tide is shifting,
and it looks like Gunn and Safran are ditching
anything that contains the baggage of the past as
they move forward. Fans have a lot to get over,
and Gunn has to bring something
monumental to help that along.